[Music]
hi I'm Sequoia Holmes I just took an
ancestry DNA kit test and my results
were super surprising so today I'm gonna
be making a dish that dates back to my
earliest ancestors today I'm gonna ease
myself into it make something really
simple I'm gonna make a meal with mojo
sauce and grilled chicken when I first
got my ancestry DNA results I was really
surprised at how specific the results
were I was really shocked to see Benina
on there I knew nothing about Benin I
was really excited and immediately
started researching everything that I
could find about it I found out that it
was the birthplace of voodoo thought
that was really cool also found out that
they have a really vibrant food scene
I'm a very beginner cook so I wanted to
go easy on myself and choose something
that wasn't gonna be super difficult I
chose a miwo which you probably have
never heard of it's a really simple
authentic savory cake I would compare it
to polenta you can serve this with fried
chicken grilled chicken sometimes fish
but I chose grilled chicken today
because it's easy I grew up eating a lot
of barbecue my mom owned a few barbecue
restaurants
I feel like barbecue the way that I know
it in soul food the way that I know it
are both American cuisines all I could
connect to was America and American
cuisine specifically so it was really
important for me to be able to get a
deeper sense of self now we're gonna
make a mojo sauce mojo sauce has red
peppers habanero pepper and has the
coolest name ever mojo sauce yes I like
a little bit of a kick a little bit of a
spice in my food when you add a habanero
it gives it just a tiny bit of a cake
but nothing major and if you don't like
any spice at all feel free to leave out
the habanero entirely now that I have my
DNA results I'm really happy to share it
with my family share this a meal with my
family see what they think of it I think
they're gonna love it my mom would be so
proud of me for making this on my own I
encourage everyone out there to do the
same this has been such a cool
experience for me now that I've made
this dish I can move on to the rest of
my DNA results I have so much left to
explore and I can't wait
[Music]
oh my god this is so good
[Music]